as a dangerous new phase of the war in
yemen begun two houthi missiles are
intercepted over the united arab
emirates in the second attack in a week
so can the entire gulf region be dragged
into yemen's conflict this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
imran khan the capital of the united
arab emirates is 1200 kilometers from
the battlefields of yemen's civil war
despite the distance and being separated
by the vast territory of saudi arabia
abu dhabi is now the target of houthi
ballistic missiles
what appears to be a new front in
yemen's six-year conflict opened last
monday and was repeated seven days later
two missiles were launched from yemen
towards al-dafrah air base near abu
dhabi emirati forces and the u.s patriot
defense system intercepted them but
flights into abu dhabi airport were once
again disrupted
three workers were killed near the
airport in last week's attack fuel tanks
were destroyed at a petroleum depot
nearby the uae
is part of the saudi-led coalition at
war in yemen the houthis are warning of
more emirati attacks saying foreign
companies should leave the oil-rich hub
and tourist destination
coalition commanders intensified
airstrikes on yemen during the past week
one struck a prison in say the province
killing at least 80 people another on
the port city of hodeidah knocked out
the internet for four days iran which
backs the houthis is calling for talks
we consider the expansion of the war in
yemen worrying and we demand saudi
arabia and the uae take political
measures with a constructive approach to
end human siege in yemen to end the war
and establish cease-fire in yemen and
urge yemenis to enter yemeni to yemeni
talks the continuation of the situation
is not and will not be to the betterment
of the region or either of the countries
involved in the crisis
let's bring in our guest in muscat in
oman abdullah babud a academic and
researcher focusing on the gulf region
in stockholm in sweden afraid nasser
yemen researcher at human rights watch
and in washington dc nabil khoury former
u.s diplomat in yemen and senior fellow
at the atlantic council's rafiq hariri
center for the middle east welcome to
the program let's begin in muscat in
oman is this a dangerous escalation or
just a case of the chickens coming home
to roost for the uae been involved in
the war since a partial withdrawal in
2019.
well i think this is a dangerous
escalation uh when we see our uh
capitals in the region and our cities
are being
attacked
by missiles it obviously uh doesn't bode
well for for the region and brings the
war to our uh our our towns and this and
also destroys our facilities and
destroys of course you know the uh and
the reputation of the region being a
safe region for investment and tourism
etc and i think this was expected in a
way because you know the continuation of
the war has uh ended in this situation
the gulf states that interfered in this
war in the first place
have not been able to end it and
negotiations have not led anywhere and
it seems that the war is now getting out
of
uh context and out of control where uh
you know the gulf states are being
attacked so i think this is a very uh
dangerous omen for the whole region
but not to be unexpected though um nabil
huri we've been warning of this uh the
americans have been warning that the
gulf could be
part of the war if it continued if it
continued on yet negotiations haven't
got anywhere this was to be expected
wasn't it
yes i don't think the
emirates can expect to be playing
in this war directly and indirectly
without somehow getting affected
this latest upscale in fighting is all
about the battle for marib
which is about a battle for natural
resources of yemen
in the end in any peace scenario
possible
those resources will have to be shared
by all the regions of yemen and so those
working on mediation right now
should focus on making sure that there
is a formula for everybody to share in
these natural resources
and therefore no need for fighting afra
a few people have died in abu dhabi yet
4.5 million people have been displacing
a hundred thousands of people have died
in yemen yet the international community
is up in arms about a few attacks in the
gulf i mean that seems incredibly unfair
doesn't it
yeah i mean logically speaking yeah and
and
the recent escalation also sends a clear
message that
civilians are caught between two fires
with absolute lack of accountability
for these violations by parties to the
conflicts and
uh either in yemen in the uae or saudi
arabia civilians should never should
never be an object of an of attack
but the reason escalation shows that
parties to the conflict show an
increasing disregard for civilian life
for civilian infrastructure
and for any prospect uh for ending the
suffering of millions of civilians
whether in yemen or eve even attacking
uh or targeting civilians in saudi
arabia and the uae and and and
when i say the lack of accountability is
that we've been in this conflict for
seven years without anyone getting
accountable for any of these violations
uh and and just recently the un uh uh
ended demanded
the mandate of the only international
impartial uh investigation mechanism to
document war crimes in yemen so that
gives
gives a clear
or or sends a clear message to the
parties to the to the conflict to
continue
doing violation and attacking civilians
without any consequences so civilians
are only paying the price for uh being
caught between two fires
abdullah babud in
moscow often when an escalation like
this occurs it's because one party is
absolutely desperate to strike a blow
that may seem to be definitive or at
least puts pressure uh for at least
bringing people to the talks is that
what's going on right now do you think
the houthis are desperate and they want
to bring an end to this conflict or is
it an escalation and the houthis just
have nothing else left to play for
well there are of course it's a very
complex war and very uh complex causes
for for this and i think
from my own reading is that um both
sides have
are fatigued now
because of this war the houthis were
working very hard as it were to control
marib which is the oil-rich region
and
because that kind of
help them to sort out some of the
economic and financial issues they're
they're facing
with the uae uh
supported uh
uh brigade that uh
uh that drove them out of this they you
know they're they're now trying to
escalate
i i believe also uh the coalition is um
getting tired of this uh it's a very
costly war uh in terms of economics and
in terms of even you know reputation and
politics and i think everybody wants to
end the war but no one really wants to
talk about the reality on the ground
they want to end the war uh as you know
on the condition that it started and
that is going to be very difficult
because things have changed
i think also both sides want to bring it
to
the the forefront of other regional and
international
crisis you know uh the yemen crisis
despite the fact that it's you know it's
costing the yemenis uh and and their
human lives and of course uh destroying
their country
no one seems to care as much uh again
given of course the multitude of
different crisis whether it is in the
region or outside the region so it seems
that by
escalating pushing this forward to bring
international and regional powers and
united nations etc to start to push
for more negotiated settlement and
that's the only way that this uh
conflict is going to be resolved i don't
think there is a military uh solution uh
and it's only if we can get all parties
sit down and talk reasonably to end the
war because enough is enough you know
the yemeni people have suffered enough
and now we are seeing that the war has
been
um we've been implicated in the gulf in
this war and our cities are being
attacked
so i think it's about time that this war
ends uh nabil khoury it's about time
that this war ends but that's a very
long way away we still have and i do i'm
going to use the term proxy war going on
in yemen between saudi arabia and iran
both key players um
how difficult is it going to be to get
those two people over to on around the
table on this particular issue when they
can't agree on several other issues
outside of yemen i mean this is fairly
low down the agenda for saudi arabia and
for uh iran right
yes i think you're uh absolutely right
uh unfortunately i don't think anybody
is really tired of this war
except the civilians who are the main
target and the main victims of this war
uh
everybody else is gearing up
and this war could go on for 10 more
years
this uh the job is for the mediators
both from the united nations and the us
to step up their game
in the end this war
is a struggle for power inside yemen to
fill the vacuum left by ali abdullah
and all sides
have ambitions to dominate the scene
these ambitions are over the top
there is no one side in yemen that can
dominate the whole country
in the end they have to share power
and the formula has to be
imposed if necessary
to make sure that everybody will have a
share in ruling this country
but they cannot dominate
the
regional powers intervening
are all intervening for their own
purposes
not for the purpose of helping yemen
and this is the job for the big powers
especially the us
to get the regional players out of yemen
once and for all
we'll continue to talk about the
politics in just a moment but i want to
bring in afra nasser here and talk about
the human rights
side of this
it seems that every side in the yemeni
conflict has human rights abuses on its
ledger um can you just talk us through
what sort of human rights abuses we're
looking at
look there is no conflict between these
destructive policies and the human
rights violations
so if there were like
any consequence or any any
uh mechanism to
hold abusers accountable we would see
some progress whether politically or in
the human rights front so uh you have
like as the war drags on so many armed
conflicts uh armed groups that were
created along uh the
the continuation of the conflict so
starting from the houthi-armed group and
sana or the saudi-led coalition and uae
backed yemeni forces and saudi uh backed
yemeni forces in the south
different groups have been committing a
a wide range of violations against
civilians so you have like a crisis of
forcible
detention
arbitrary detention
forcible disappearance uh starvation
uh
unlawful attacks uh
whether using messiahs rackets uh the
conduct of hostility is just reckless
from every party in this conflict and at
the same time you have backers and
supporters from the us uk france germany
you name it that they see these mounting
documentation of violations whether from
international human rights groups like
human rights watch amnesty and other
groups they see all these documentation
and these reports coming even from you
and you and human rights council reports
that
show that there there is a you know a
widespread of of violation and some of
them that could amount to war crimes in
yemen and yet these states and europe
and the us uh these world leaders
continue to support uh uh parties to the
conflict without any consideration to
the human human life uh and human
in in the conflict it's just uh
really bizarre and and frustrating right
the bias that you see at the moment
while yemenis are being bombed since uh
the uae was attacked and on 17th of
january it just tells you how the the
international community is under
pressure and being biased to uh saudi
arabia and the uae thanks to their big
influence well let's talk about that
with uh abdullah our guest in washington
dc uh nabil huri actually said that this
could this wall could go on for another
10 years however is there any thinking
in the uae right now given the litany of
human rights abuses that we've just
heard about given the escalation into
uae territory that actually enough is
enough that we do need to stop this war
because it's now coming to our doorstep
yes patriot defense missile system is
working the uae have managed to um
destroy the missiles that came in but
this is just the tip of the iceberg
uh i i agree uh i think it is very
difficult to defend against uh such
attacks
and maybe uh one can be successful in
several times it only needs one missile
to get through
and it is the psychological impact
rather than of course you know the the
attack itself uh that has an impact on
the region um you know when the cities
in the gulf that are going through
development and it's you know want to
attract investment and tourism uh et
cetera
and now being attacked obviously this is
going to have an impact especially in
the uae because
unlike saudi arabia the uae doesn't have
the strategic depth that saudi arabia
has and
and of course it is it's gonna this is
gonna affect it really badly and i
believe that uh the leadership in the
united arab emirates is going to work
very hard uh to try and
to uh you know to escalate and and
possibly now they got more involved in
the war they probably will have a say as
they did not do before and trying to end
the war uh because
now they are implicated uh in the war
more than they were uh before obviously
they withdrew uh at a certain stage and
now they are back and they're being
attacked so i think uh maybe the united
arab emirates now can push for
uh further uh de-escalation and and
further talks and i believe there is
something going on at the moment it's
difficult to tell but i think there are
some uh meetings taking place where the
united arab emirates wants to play a
role in in trying to resolve this
conflict because uh you know negotiation
between the houthis and saudi arabia
hasn't led anywhere uh in the past and
also with the legitimate government and
it requires pressure and it requires
pressure as navigate from the global
powers especially from the united states
from the european union um from china
and russia and from the united nations
that they must end this war obviously um
you know a war like this there are uh uh
there is a war economy there are a lot
of people who benefited from the war and
who want to continue with the war but i
think the states themselves are tired
in a way i i think this has been very
costly war for saudi arabia um
financially but also in terms of
reputation and i don't think the saudis
want this to uh to continue either but i
think everybody has to come to a
recognition that you know you cannot
continue the uh bombarding cities and
you cannot continue this war and there
is no winner at the end and everybody
has to give a given something or give up
something
for a peaceful resolution of of the
conflict this is a very complicated
conflict it's probably more complicated
than uh the palestinian-israeli conflict
because of the so many different uh
factions and interests in in
uh nabil khoury you've just heard what
our guest in moscow has had to say do
you still think that this could go on
for another 10 years does that does his
words give you any kind of hope for a
quick a quicker resolution to the
conflict
uh i was a bit optimistic at the
beginning of the biden administration
due to their focus and they're sending a
special envoy uh to help end the yemen
war but now a year past that mark and
nothing absolutely nothing has been
achieved
my optimism has evaporated
the uae should be motivated
for peace but i don't see them making
any move for mediation or suing for
peace
on the contrary the uae has been
establishing a maritime empire that
spreads from dubai through the horn of
africa and and up to suez canal to north
africa they are very ambitious
and with that ambition
i don't see them all that concerned i
mean they have good defenses and their
main cities will probably be defended
against any incoming rockets and the
rockets in the end of the day
will not change the balance of power
that much the balance of power is
overwhelmingly in the air
on the side of the arab coalition
on the ground it's a it's a different
matter
and
i think uh it's the mediators job to
really focus
made a very good
effort
but
oman
can't impose anything if both sides
don't accept to come to the table
oman can only offer ideas
but in the end of the day it's the big
powers uh at the united nations the u.n
security council that must agree with
one another and that must impose a
solution
um
is absolutely uh correct about the bias
the i am ashamed that our own state
department
after what happened i mean the houthis
foolishly fired the few rockets sorry
sorry we are running out of time and i
do want to come to afronasser you've
just mentioned her there this is the
worst humanitarian crisis
currently on the planet um
and with everything our guests have just
been talking about there's no quick
solution to this it's only going to get
worse yet
not only do we have donor fatigue when
it comes to kind of dealing with this
conflict but we also have political
fatigue as well people just don't want
to get involved do they internationally
yeah so
as you just mentioned
this is the
the world's worst humanitarian crisis
and at the same time in my opinion it's
the world's worst political crisis
uh there seems to be uh political
fatigue donor fatigue at the same time
even the u.s administration is talking
about uh considering to redis redesign
uh the houthis as terrorist group which
will have serious implications for
millions of civilians uh look both sides
attacks cannot be justified by
other side
apparent and lawful attacks so
what we need here is uh justice really
no peace no justice and no justice no
peace what houthis were being able to do
is because there is no consequences what
the saudi-led coalition have been
able to do is because there is no
consequences
yemen is in desperate need of
accountability uh the bias that dr
nabeel just mentioned it's just shameful
and disgraceful
and
you know the international community
should condem
abusers and violators of all sides this
is the least thing that not only yemenis
all civilians deserve whether in yemen
in the uae saudi arabia civilians
deserve uh solidarity from the
international sorry afro we are running
out we are running out of time and i do
want to come to just very quickly
abdullah given everything you've heard
from stockholm and washington dc there
do you still believe that this attack
could
lead to a quicker resolution to the
conflict now that the uae it's come to
the uae's borders
do you still believe that i don't think
it will lead to a quicker uh resolution
but i think it will uh move the waters a
little bit and i think we have seen that
now um you know the international u.n uh
special envoy the u.s special envoy are
visiting the region and they are talking
i think there is a lot of uh discussions
going on between the leaders in the
region
so i i think it is it is uh
uh it is uh it has nudged uh the
conflict a little bit more to the
forefront of international politics
because it's been neglected
for for many reasons and that is wrong
because we are seeing people being
killed and suffering
next to us and there is a huge
humanitarian crisis that's being said
and the world at large ignore this
conflict letting them just you know get
on with it so i think this is going to
at least bring this to the forefront and
there is there are some discussions and
i think the more uh attacks happens in
the cities even if they don't succeed
the fear of of those attacks and of
course their reputational uh damage
is going to uh have an effect on in the
gulf states you know we're we're small
countries uh we're you know peaceful
countries and they're
trying to build their economies on uh
diversification and investment and so on
and this is going to have a really bad
reputation for uae and for saudi arabia
and for the whole region at large if
this is going to continue for a long
time so i think there must be a solution
to this
i do want to thank all our guests
abdullah babud afranasir and nabil
khoury and i want to thank you as well
for watching you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me imran khan and
the whole team here bye for now
[Music]